[Music]
this is a ciliate just a eukaryotic
microbe waving its cilia around under
our microscope and this is the same
ciliate and yep here it is again and
again but as you're probably noticing
while the rough outline of this organism
seems the same from shot to shot the
cilia itself in the world around it
clearly look very different colors
change details are more apparent in one
case the organism seems to be lit from
within on this channel we're constantly
flipping between different ways of
capturing images of organisms so which
one of them is what they actually look
like well none of them anything you see
through a microscope is an image which
in our case means that everything we
show you on this channel every frame is
not the microbial world itself it's an
interpretation of the life on the other
side of our objective translated through
the lens into details and shapes and
colors all affected by the way we light
up the life we want to see
light is amazing it's also very weird it
travels and waves and as it interacts
with particles and materials it scatters
and shifts even if we can't actually see
those light waves in motion so much of
what we observe in the world around us
is rooted in the physical properties
that define those waves like how we can
observe certain frequencies of light as
colors but waves have far more to them
than just their frequency and microscopy
has combined the resourcefulness of many
different Sciences to use light to give
us different ways to peer into the
microbial world so let's start simple
good old-fashioned white light early
microscopists used oil lamps and
sunlight to see through their
microscopes and while the technology has
changed the simplicity of this has
endured into the modern technique of
bright field microscopy it all starts
with a source of light though modern
microscopes have their lamps built-in
set up underneath the stage that holds
our sample light travels from the source
through a condenser which works to focus
the light onto the sample above it this
focused light travels through the sample
towards the objective lens which takes
in an image and magnifies it into these
bright backgrounds with organisms
sometimes rendered transparent by the
intensity of the light you might say
that this is as close as we get to
seeing what the micro cosmos actually
looks like but that would be like taking
a 2000 watt light bulb into your living
room and saying this is what my home
looks like light effects things and
we're not even shining light on these
organisms were shining light through
them now bright field might seem
relatively simple but that simplicity
has been incredibly power
full and allowing scientists old and new
to wade through microscopic waters still
there are limitations to consider with
any scientific technique and one of the
major challenges for bright field
microscopy particularly when looking at
microbes is contrast pigmented organisms
are easy to visualize against the bright
background but in cases where the
organism has been rendered transparent
it can be harder to distinguish their
bodies from the rest of the world they
inhabit scientists can navigate these
challenges using stains that make
certain structures more visible but for
our purposes would like to avoid stains
because they can affect the microbes
themselves there are other ways though
to contend with this challenge one of
which is built on one of those simple
yet strange properties of our world you
don't always need to shine light
directly onto an object to see it this
technique is called dark field
microscopy which sounds like it must be
almost the opposite of bright field
microscopy it's not the two techniques
are actually very similar light travels
from a source through a condenser goes
through the sample and then it travels
into the objective lens producing the
image we see but what we wanted dark
field microscopy is for the beam of
light to hit the sample but not our eye
so in dark field microscopy a circular
disk is placed inside the condenser
blocking the central part of the light
from shining through the sample and into
our eye or our camera this means that
when there is no sample on the slide all
you see is black but the disk doesn't
block all of the light there's still a
hollow cone of light that travels around
the disk unable to reach the objective
or our eyes but that still hits the
sample when it does
those microscopic transparent bodies
scatter those hidden rays into our
review and as they do an image of their
bodies forms against a dark background
providing us with this almost cinematic
footage another method to get better
contrast than bright field microscopy is
called phase contrast microscopy and
it's built on working with a property of
light that we can't actually directly
experience microbes are really anything
that is easily visually observed with
bright field microscopy are called
amplitude objects because as light
passes through them the amplitude of the
light wave changes which we see as
changes in light intensity but there is
another class of specimens these are
called phase objects as light passes
through these objects the waves slowed
down and shift slightly in phase
compared to the unaffected light around
it and if you're wondering what that
means in terms of what we can see that's
the issue our eyes don't process these
differences in phase and so in the final
image these objects or in our case
organisms are very difficult to see
[Music]
while in the 1930s a physicist named
fritz arnica developed a method to shift
the direct light just slightly enough so
that these changes in phase could
actually be translated into changes in
amplitude producing an image of these
formerly hard to see phase objects by
essentially treating them as amplitude
objects there's a lot of physics in this
that we're not gonna get into but the
result was so important that it would
eventually winds arnica the Nobel Prize
in Physics and of course selfishly we
here appreciate his work because it lets
us see more of our hidden microbial
friends and for the last type of
microscopy we'll go over today we're
gonna be getting into another property
of light that we can't directly see and
this one can make the micro cosmos glow
most of the light we see has an article
field that vibrates and all sorts of
planes relative to the direction the
light is traveling in but that vibration
can be restricted to just one plane and
when that happens the light is said to
be polarized we can't see the difference
between polarized and unpolarized light
and you might see the difference in how
the world looks when you're wearing
polarized sunglasses but these changes
are brought about by changes in color or
intensity not the polarization of the
light itself so when does polarized
light help microscopy well a lot of
materials stay the same optically
speaking no matter what direction you
shoot light at them from but there are
certain materials where specific
properties like how fast light travels
through them can vary depending on which
way the light is striking them these
materials called optically anisotropic
can also take in array of light and
divide it into two separate beams
by aiming polarized light at our sample
and then reconstructing an image based
on how the various parts of the organism
interacts with that restricted light
particularly by how it might cause that
light to split we can see more of these
optically anisotropic materials in
action in our case it often takes the
form of shiny internal crystals
[Music]
so we've given you the big overview of
what these different techniques can do
let's go back and look at what that
means for that original ciliate we
started with here it is under bright
field microscopy the background is
bright the image produced by changes in
light amplitude that allow us to see the
overall shape but some of the detail is
hard to make out under dark field though
the contrast increases and some of those
details become more obvious displaying
compartments and cilia in greater detail
that are also apparent under phase
contrast and then under polarized light
the crystals that blend it in with the
organism previously are now visible and
vibrant now of course there are many
other microscopy techniques that use
light in many different ways but we
think it's incredible that with just
these for the world of the micro cosmos
looks almost like different universes
wrapped up into one invisible world
around us the journey it seems is not
just about what you see but also how you
see it and ultimately none of these
views are what the micro cosmos actually
looks like either that or all of them
are our brains play tricks on us to make
us believe that the world looks one way
but the world looks different at night
than in the day and both of those things
have more to do with the physiology of
our eyes and our brains than with the
objective reality asking what a microbe
actually looks like is to some extent
forcing our own experience onto
something that is beyond it which is not
something I ever would have thought of
if it weren't for this little youtube
channel
this is the last episode of our first
season of journey to the micro cosmos
it's been really wonderful and don't
worry we're just gonna take a week off
and then we will be back with our second
season featuring more of our microbial
buddies and their various antics thank
you for coming on this journey with us
as we explore the unseen world that
surrounds us and especially thank you to
all of these people our patrons on
patreon who make it possible for us to
take such a deep and interested look at
this wonderful world thank you everybody
for being a part of that if you want to
see more from our master of microbes
James you can check out Jam and germs on
Instagram and if you want to be here and
ready for next season go to youtube.com
slash micro cosmos
[Music]